2016 has already brought us lots of excellent
games to enjoy—so many that it's tough to
narrow down the absolute best of the bunch.
Nevertheless, we've got something for every
kind of gamer when it comes to the best games
of the year...so far.
Here's Looper's top seven video games for
the first half of 2016.
Dark Souls III
Dark Souls III is all about dungeon crawling,
fighting difficult enemies, and dying...a
lot.
When you think you've mastered your character,
all it takes is one botched dodge to totally
wreck you.
The world of Dark Souls III is absolutely
gorgeous, with plenty of lore to discover—assuming
you don't throw your controller out the window
first.
XCOM 2
Finding out that humans lost the war against
the aliens who invaded during the first game
is a bit of a bummer.
But this turn-based tactics game is filled
with unpredictable missions that'll test your
fortitude.
Just don't get too attached to your squad—'cuz
they're probably gonna die.
Sneaking onto the battlefield to fight ruthless
aliens is always a fun, nail-biting experience.
And if you're lucky, you might even survive.
The Witness
Nobody would've expected a 3D puzzler to do
so well in an era defined by Halo and Call
of Duty.
But fans of the classic Myst games will enjoy
The Witness, which exercises your brain rather
than your reflexes.
Gamers explore an open-world island filled
with unconventional, thought-provoking puzzles.
The Witness puts you in a world that'll inspire
plenty of "eureka!"
moments.
And actually reaching its true ending puts
your wits and creativity to the test.
Fire Emblem Fates
Fire Emblem Fates: Birthright, Conquest, and
Revelation are all slightly different versions
of the same game, but they all offer some
of the best RPG experiences of the year so
far.
The series' rock-paper-scissors approach to
combat is streamlined here enough to make
things captivating and engaging even for series
vets.
The plot between the three versions of the
game relies heavily on politics and scheming,
and depending which version of the game you
get, the story events and the unit classes
you'll have access to will be drastically
different.
Play all of them.
Hyper Light Drifter
Hyper Light Drifter might be one of the best
games of the year.
The vibrant colors make Hyper Light Drifter
stand out, while its controls and its combat
system are fantastic.
Exploring never gets boring or repetitive,
and as you play, you learn more about the
world and its dangers.
Soon, you'll be completely sucked in and never
want to leave.
Uncharted 4: A Thief's End
The fourth game in the Uncharted series is
already a modern classic.
After enjoying monumental success with the
first three installments, developer Naughty
Dog rose to the the challenge and topped themselves.
Uncharted 4 exceeded expectations, ending
the series on a high note.
"Thanks."
"Aw, this is nuts!"
With great storytelling and amazingly gorgeous
visuals and gameplay, Uncharted 4 is a must-buy
for all PS4-owners.
Overwatch
What can we say about Blizzard's team-based
shooter Overwatch that hasn't been said a
thousand times already?
That it managed to breathe new life into a
tired genre?
That it's got something to offer every type
of player?
That its cast of colorful characters, tight
controls, and fantastic visuals all contribute
to it being simply one of the most fun games
to come out this year?
Yeah—that about covers all of it.
Go get Overwatch.
We'll be waiting for you.
And thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave a comment to let us know which games
you think should have made the list...